so the RTC wants to help make sure that
you stay safe while you're out catching
a bus ride during these dangerously hot
temperatures Candace Charles is out at
the Bonneville Transit Center this
morning to tell us more about how
they're doing that good morning Candace
good morning good morning folks yes sir
helping people stay cool already it's
been pretty hot this morning RDC has
cooling stations as well as some
giveaways to keep folks relaxed as
possible in this heat it's all a part of
their summer heat campaign and I'm
joined by rtc's McKenzie Coons Embry
thank you so much for joining us tell us
a little bit about this summer heat
campaign and some cooling tips as well
that's always helpful absolutely when we
know it's hot out there right and our
Transit customers really bear the brunt
of that heat traveling in and around the
valley so we want to make sure that we
give them the resources necessary to
keep cool so we have sunscreen water
tons of resources but really we want to
make sure our Riders also have tips you
know what I mean you know we really want
to make sure that they're wearing
lighter clothing bring your water
bottles make sure you're using our ride
RTC app to plan your trip so you never
have to wait really more than in 10
minutes or really what's necessary when
you're outside we really are trying to
make sure that people don't have don't
have to wait a long time outside just to
make sure they're really reducing that
risk of heat it's it's a brutal one
right now absolutely we've been talking
about the successive heat warning for
the last couple of days so hopefully
people are getting prepared they're also
making this a fun experience right it's
still summer so tell us a little bit
about how you guys are doing that yes
absolutely so we are out at our
Bonneville Transit Center and our South
Strip Transit terminal every week and
then we also drive around town um
passing out giveaways but today we're
here we have our Plinko game we want to
make it fun I love to go yes of course
well feel free if you would like oh
awesome well I already won something I
did get some of my glasses because I
gotta block out them haters and my
future is so bright but this time I'm
gonna try to see what else I could win
I'm gonna step over here and see I got a
little chip here okay let's go I'm
hoping for a water bottle lip balm oh
and I got a water bottle because I'm so
awesome thank you so much we appreciate
you McKenzie and they'll be out here
every week for the entire summer all the
way till the first week of September as
uh Mackenzie mentioned they're also
riding around giving away stuff as well
the day after they're at the transit
centers you can find out more details
about the summer heat campaign on our
website newsnow.com for now live from
the Bonneville Transit Center in
downtown Las Vegas I'm Candace Charles 8
News Now